what the is going on I like to party
Jesus honey wax this is unwaxed get in
lizard we're going shopping with Sophia
and cine Salone did we just become best
friends
[Music]
y oh I didn't bring my just like I
didn't bring my
journal you did that on purpose you did
that I swear to God you I was do book
reviews and I forgot about it we were
rushing Out start the not recorded I'm
about to go off didn't mean well well
well well hello everybody and welcome
back to another episode of the
care I didn't mean to I'm mad at you
Sophia you lost a bet and you were
supposed to bring your journal in that
doesn't mean I'm not going to bring the
journal in I just forgot cuz I was doing
book reviews checking out my favorite
book club you know what you are you're a
tease not to me you call us teases for
every scenario I'm
not you just kissed this guy on the
cheek and said have a good night and
you're leaving all of us all of us
wanting more I'll do it next episode I
promise that's what they all say I'll
call you back I brought the book last
time I was I'll make AZ none of it comes
through maybe subconsciously I just did
not want to bring it because I was
scared if anyone doesn't remember from
last episode I lost a bed I was supposed
to read my private journal entry and let
me just say I have never read it to
anyone like cinee knows I know she's
tempted to read it so many times but
I've gone in your room and just been
nosy for 10 minutes is crazy can we be
totally honest right now between the two
of us what have you no no have you gone
through my drawers no no Tom remember we
went through
Scarlets that was not cool that was not
cool we I will admit that was not right
we shouldn't have done that but her ENT
were funny so funny she was also in
fourth grade I think she yeah she was in
fourth grade I think she was mad at me
one day and she was like I'm mad at
Sophia she's being like she spelled like
brat wrong or something it was like it
was the best and then I think she talked
about oh I don't even know if I should
expose her on this but she had a lot of
crushes that girl is boy crazy in
elementary school yeah that wasn't
me you weren she wasn't no you weren't
so no I didn't mean to forget it I'll
bring it next time even though I
reluctantly I'm only doing one entry I'm
not doing three can I pick what you have
to read it depends because I actually
you know what the only thing I'll say
totally off limits is last year and part
of this year like you're I'm not I am
not
reading okay fine maybe
no I'm I'm just gonna say yes and no I
you can say like a random month and I'll
give you a I don't want to do it if you
were to judge me I'm not like very fine
okay you know I was anxious enough today
and you're just adding to my unwanted
Stress and Anxiety yeah s's been saying
she's so tired today all day but she's
just been thinking so hard today that's
making her tired bra feels like there's
steam coming out of it like it's on
overdrive one one thing that was a
surprise to wake up to this morning was
season two of the family Stallone
trailer came out yeah and there I am
blindfolded in the trailer with a boy
kissing me on the face she did some
other things with this on the stage
you're guys you're acting like what did
I do on stage you kissed him on stage
you kissed him on stage do you want me
to ruin it for people Direction he
kissed me okay so she was on stage I
actually forced her to do this this is
such a good idea but watching this
trailer back and already seeing the
responses from people again I look boy
crazy The Producers took my love life
and they said let's just stop steroid
this process and make it look absolutely
10 times more than is wait stop saying
you quote look boy crazy last episode
you were saying I have so many dates
this week with so many men you are boy
crazy in your era 2024 I encourage it
you know what's funny but cuz you're
just as single as me right now and you
complain just as much as I do about it I
something the scarlet and her boyfriend
I was on the phone with them the other
day and they
said what's going on with Sophia why
doesn't she have anyone she's not going
on any dates she's not even trying a
concern in a family that absolutely it's
a concern why why haven't you been
putting yourself out there it's just one
month I kissed someone on New Year's
it's been 30 days no I'm just saying
even before him there wasn't really much
movement happening yeah since like
October are you
good don't cry no I'm like sobbing here
no I'm fine I just there's just I think
I just Adit a different mindset I you
know what truly I don't know when it
rains it pours some some months I'm
doing great some months I have
absolutely zero and I feel like that
happens question does it make you feel
worse about your love life because
you're going on a bachelorette trip this
weekend no because I feel like
Bachelorette trip single is pretty
fun in Utah Maybe not maybe not maybe
meet a nice Mormon boy okay yep I mean
my best friend lives there so I she can
introduce me going have to give up some
coffee I'm excited well okay I feel like
batch the trips can go one or two ways I
feel like it depends on the I've been to
a three total damn and what this you're
like the only single one left in your
whole friend group that's no my friend
Kaylee's single shout out
Kay she going to love that no so we're
going to Utah this weekend um which I I
love I went there last year L the skiing
but I just haven't I don't know what you
do wait why were you there last year
well no maybe not yeah it was last year
it was last year last February what were
you doing in Utah when I was with my
last boyfriend we did a coup's trip so
I'm going back single I was there not
single and now I'm going back single no
I'm excited but you know what it is I
I'm getting really anxious before I
leave I'm really like I do anyone get
travel anxiety like I I can travel but I
get anxious before I hit you know like
there's so many outfits I need to pack
all my toiletries well that's what funny
about a bachelorette trip it's every
single day there's a theme yeah what are
your them oh yeah so the first so yeah I
actually think these themes are pretty
funny so the first one's kind of like
Salt Lake City Housewives like so you
know like Bravo you wear the big fur
coats and like the fun big eyeglasses
with when you are in snow whatever at
night and then the next one is snow
princess that one was tricky and let me
explain why cuz I know you guys all care
about this we can't wear white right and
I feel like snow princess even on a
bachelorette trip is that a rule oh yeah
you can't wear white at all at anything
seems kind of selfish you need to go to
more
weddings I'm 25 who's getting married
that's like my age it's going to come
give it give it a year I would in I
would hope by then I'd have a plus fun
with
me I know my girlfri and I got separate
rooms for the wedding and we decided to
conjoin rooms cuz we we were banking
last year we go oh yeah we'll find
someone for the wedding now she's my
date oh I know but we every night's a
different theme we're going out I'm
excited um I've been well actually I'm
excited because I've been doing sober
January so kicking it off kicking it off
back to drinking in February with The
Bachelorette trip so finally cuz I'm
carrying these drunk stories on my back
for this I'm going to carry a story when
I come back here thank God you're
welcome thank you yeah pull your weight
oh oh oh oh oh because I just read this
that we have written down you guys I
just want to reiterate something
manifestations are real and people you
bring up in the past
randomly will somehow be a part of your
life this is not the same thing no it is
this is not it is okay and I'm going to
explain this to you right now I just I
would say that on Sunday was probably
the best day of my entire life of my
entire life that's true actually and
it's not even a big claim it is the
claim because let me just start out by
first s and I found found our Dream
apartment and we got confirmed that it
is our apartment yay
he chose us yes he chose us two while we
were eating dinner we were kind of
annoyed because we like to watch reality
shows and we were like what are we going
to watch this is like our problem of the
night like which one have we not bed
yeah we finished all of them we actually
finished every reality show which is
probably more of a concern that we
should no no no I like to call it
research we're on a reality show I guess
it's just for research it's just
research we turn on the TV love Island
All Stars love Island All
Stars so bad I was like Wow could it get
any better we're walking back let me cut
to a couple months ago before he was
famous I don't have celebrity crushes I
have I have I'm like oh yeah this
athlete's kind of cute or this actor is
kind of cute but I'm I'm not the person
that watches thirst traps over and over
like C will send me some of Roman Reign
or like you've talked about this a 100
times in the podcast I'm not outing you
and I just I was never that girl I like
Thought Justin Bieber was cute but I
just didn't have like a 100 posters on
my wall we neither one of us
did I was just scrolling Tik Tok as a
millennial does of course and I come
across this video of this guy I had a
physical reaction like my stomach
flip-flopped and I was like I'm in love
I'm in love with this I'm not
exaggerating when I say it you mention
this actor's name probably prob three
times a day for the last two months but
no even before that a lot at least once
a day now it's it's been once it was it
was once a week it was more internal
Obsession and now it's like a little bit
more hour but I just thought he was so
handsome like wow and so SC sending me
all these videos you're sending me these
videos his name is Callum Turner you
guys have probably heard of him now
because he's dating dualipa he's also in
a bunch of shows that just came out but
at the time that I saw him he what none
of these have come out and can I just
stop you right there what every single
time you like get fixated on something
you say I was the first to discover it
you said you're the first to discover
that colum Turner was hot every time
there's a new song you're like look at
this new song I found I found it before
anyone else did like you did though we
were on Sophia with an F podcast and I
said Cal she had no idea who he was I
guarantee she she also didn't know
anyone that I was saying yeah we didn't
know who she cuz you're talking about
WWE stars of course you wouldn't know
who WWE is it's a big franchise it's a
big franchise but not not usually for
our for our age range fine so
demographic whatever so I'm not saying I
was the first to discover him but it was
before the hype around him came okay
okay so cut to the best day ever Sunday
this man lives in London London London
we're walking a block away from our
apartment right cine turns over and
looks at me and goes that's colum
Turner she thought I was full of [__]
and I
don't play you're lying and she goes no
no no it's him cuz that's something I
would lie about I crossed the street
turn around lo and behold is my
celebrity crush on our street on our
street what are the odds that on our
street a guy that I've brought up and
discovered the only celebrity crush I've
ever had in my life yeah was on our
block yeah you made a circle it three
times I made a circle I I he was waiting
to dig inside I like kind of touched him
with my elbow a little bit you're so you
were trying to do like a meat C I didn't
want him to notice me I just wanted to
see if I could like how close I can get
you okay he's not famous enough where
he's like Justin Bieber has like 100
bodyguards like he had just that is
crazy what are the odds he on our stre
come on by the way better looking in
person he is this is where don't meet
your Idols isn't in meet your idol met
him he's not my idol he's just my crush
but it was the best thing in my life
back anyway so we are really do you want
to I want to intro it oh my God you're
being such a pain in the ass today
Sophia hates me you guys but we decided
to do another round of listener
questions you guys really responded well
to our love advice ones so this one's
kind of a little bit of everything we
asked what do you guys want to know
we're here to give some answers Again by
no means do we have any expertise in any
of these fields um I beg to differ I
actually think these questions were way
more in tandem to what we go through in
our daily lives than usual I think the
love stui was a little bit there was a
little bit I guess I'm just nervous to
um say something that some old man on
Tik Tok is going to stitch and then
completely roast me because I've been
getting that yeah getting a lot so take
it with a grain of salt doesn't have to
apply to everyone yeah also I loved the
reactions from last episode they act
people were saying that last episodes um
you know advice that we were giving just
based off like advice about guys and
responding even my Journey was really
positive so I I love I read your guys'
DMs not the creepy guys but the the
girls the girls I listen to this love
you so we'll start with the first one
and I can read it and then we'll just
see who wants to answer it how to get
through a friendship breakup that didn't
have
closure I think for me personally that's
a tough one because people can compare
you know breaking up with a boyfriend or
girlfriend as equivalent or even harder
than you know a friendship I would argue
it's harder yeah and you know for me
personally cuz I've had a friendship
breakup before and you kind of just have
to take it as it's meant to be sometimes
and sometimes in life you know things
will happen between the two of you maybe
you know you'll outgrow each other or
maybe you've been with each other too
long that you need space and I know it's
really tough but you kind of have to see
it as what I've said before which is
people come into your lives at certain
points and people leave when needed and
I had a situation I think uh with my
friend not I think I know I had a
situation a couple years ago with my
friend um from high school I don't want
to say her name but I think you can kind
of remember we had a huge fight in high
school she was my closest friend ever
like ever my sister Morning Noon night
she was a part of my family we had one
major fight and when I tell you we had
that fight and didn't talk to each other
for probably three and a half years yeah
that was horrible for me like I was so
devastated I thought about her probably
every single day wondering what she was
up to and I never thought we could come
back around again mhm but because I gave
you know us the patience to grow and her
to grow we ended up coming back together
and having a conversation and now I
still consider her one of my closest
friends yeah dealing with a friendship
is kind of tricky unless you have one of
those dialogues that is so open and
honest where if your friend made a
mistake you could just easily FaceTime
her and say what the hell are you doing
or why would you do that if you don't
have that relationship which is pretty
hard to come across I would agree that
time does heal all wounds and if it's
meant to be that you guys come back
together and hopefully you have one of
those friendships where space is good
and then when you come back together
it's almost like no time has passed yeah
so unfortunately unless you want to be
the bigger person and really try to give
it one
last chance and Salvage it go for it but
if not gosh there's nothing you can do I
would recommend cuz I also recently went
through a friend breakup reaching out to
as many new girlfriends as possible and
do it shamelessly and one's going to
stick and it's going to be so much fun
you're going to be so happy and it's
almost like that
void is going to be filled yeah like
you'll feel satisfied and you're getting
exactly what you want out of a companion
but I can pretty much guarantee that
there will be some sort of reunion hope
at we hope Point yeah okay the last
several first dates I've been on have
been horrible how do I bounce back from
it I can relate I would say do not feel
discouraged because so often I'm coming
home from these dates and I'm calling my
mom and I'm complaining why is it so
hard is it me I feel like I can't find
any good guys anymore it's so important
to not feel discouraged but I also think
giving yourself a little bit of a a
break from dating if it continues to
happen it can be so draining and so
exhausting and if it's not good for your
mental health overall just sort of like
take a few just take two weeks for
yourself I was going to say the exact
same thing I I get look I'm in the same
boat right now I mean this cine just
made a comment about why I haven't been
on so many dates and you know I do
believe though you have to kiss a few
frogs to find your prints I know that
sounds cheesy but as sinee said taking a
step back and re-evaluating is always
the best thing because I feel like if
you're forcing something and it doesn't
end up good you're going to feel even
worse about it go off your instinct when
you get back in and you dip your toe
into the dating Pond trust your gut
because you can usually weed out the
good ones from the bad ones if you're
really listening to your intuition
rather than your desperation I hate
taking accountability for things that
aren't working out in my life but this
is something that you maybe need to ask
yourself why is it that I'm going on so
many bad dates and I ask myself that and
I've realized that it's I'm choosing
quantity over quality I'm going out with
guys I'm saying yes to guys even though
they already possess certain traits that
I wouldn't want in a partner so maybe be
more specific be more picky write down a
list of your absolute yeses and NOS that
you need and if they don't have that
then don't say yes just because mhm okay
that's what I wrote for my NOS list
um the next one is best hinge prompts to
use okay should I read mine sure I was
actually talking about this with my guy
friend the other day and he went through
my hinge and he said he hated all of my
prompts really because he said that
you're making it difficult for men to be
able to respond to any of them oh so I
said okay that's funny because I wrote
that down as like the thing that you
need to use for a hinge prompt like my
most controversial opinion because that
allows you know someone to kind of see
your personality and you know kick start
the conversation okay this is a really
good one and I think people should steal
it so my first one is the question says
the best way to ask me out is by and I
said a boom box outside my window like
every single guy says the same thing
what song am I playing or they'll
recommend a song or they'll send me a
Spotify link or send me the address I'm
outside your window can't you hear me
like it literally is the best one that
they respond to okay the next one I said
how to pronounce my name see you can't
really use this one cuz I just said like
the chapel yeah basic
okay oh this next one's a little spicy
this is a new one I just added oh I
don't it my last one was very wholesome
it was about playing chess this one I
don't know I thought I I thought it was
one I created for you what you what you
create um I can't sell smell I can't
stand the smell of eggs yeah that's
really hot Sophia I can't stand the
smell of eggs on a dating profile some
people can't see I wrote I wrote Oh
God actually this one is getting a lot
of responses to you but you'll see why
the question is dating me is like and I
said getting complimentary
dessert oh my God E I know honestly e
e covered his face was hor no it was so
bad I'm changing I'm deleting a guy
react to it but but but but maybe
reverse psychology I'm weeding up the
weirdos because I do get some Rogue
answers and responses to that one wait
are you on are you on hinge yeah wait so
what what questions are the easiest ones
to answer like which prompts are pretty
much the ones are like okay go to any
sort of specific interest would say oh
interest so you would would you say not
like would you rather questions you
would just go for the more like
something that you can you know I prefer
something that's like a little a little
bit more of a serious interest cuz you
can like really kind of play off of that
but the wood you rathers right I see a
lot of guys like putting their favorite
author or like or they'll put like three
bands or whatever something where if a
girl sees and she goes oh I really like
that too and then that in instantly
starts the conversation I think that's
what makes hinge easy because you don't
really start at the hey how are you good
you can just sort of jump halfway into
the conversation that's a good idea
don't listen to mine don't Lally the
first one was good the rest sucked can
you delete that last one it's so ick we
can figure this out later all right it's
tough let's we'll just say that last
prompt was but the first one is good use
that one the best way to ask me out is
by boom box outside my window or some
girls should say by asking me out that's
boring yeah it's cliche the next one
beauty tips I have three I'm ready to go
so I I when I saw this question I really
wanted to provide with things that I
actually do use on a day-to-day basis or
just a part of my routine and I feel
like so I'm going to say glow up beauty
tips I'm not going to do like wholesome
beauty tips okay one thing I always do
when I'm doing my makeup is I put
highlighter in the corner of my eyes and
that makes your eyes pop even using
white eyeliner and I know Alex Earl made
that whole thing but white eyeliner on
the inside of your eye and highlighter
on the corners if you want a perfume to
last long I'm a big perfume girl find a
fragrance and a um what's it called
lotion with the same fragrance base like
a vanilla SE I've seen people use Aqua
for that is a that's not like a what's
what's the word that's
a petroleum jelly yeah no it's not it
doesn't work people say it works I've
tried it before but it's it just doesn't
set on the skin correctly it's all about
layering it's what you use in the shower
the oils the lotions and then layering
on top but everything has to dry down
before you apply okay and then three
suine does this too dermaplaning is
lifechanging when you can do it right
before your skin care it's so satisfying
it's so satisfying removes all the dead
skin all of the little hair and it makes
your makeup look so much better smooth
but you have to use a clean one and you
need to just be very very sensitive to
the skin the amount of times I wish I
could just tie a man down and like let
me dermaplane his whole face and fix his
eyebrows is probably once a day you
can't tell me it's the most satisfying
thing oh my God I did it the other day
and the amount of
shedding it was like I was a chameleon
like peeling I was a butterfly you snake
in a yeah I was in a cocoon and I just
like shaved off my whole face I feel
like a new human being it burns after
when you put on some no it doesn't feel
good it doesn't feel good but you got to
you got to do it and then last but not
least three things go to bed early
scrape your damn tongue that's a
non-negotiable for me and wash on the am
to deep puff that face I was thinking
this is all makeup based but you gave
like life hacks I gave up I gave glow up
tips oh but you can give your tips
beauty tips
H you didn't write any oh no I was just
going off the top of my head let's see I
wear a lot of makeup so I guess this is
for people that like to wear a lot of
makeup um Alexis Oakley who's a
professional makeup artist you've seen
her on Tik Tok she does everyone and
anyone Under the Sun she's amazing she
uh has this trick and I said I don't
know how I can make my makeup last all
night like I will go out go to dinner
when I come home I literally look like
someone already took a washcloth to my
face and I'm like where did it all go I
actually always come home from nights
out and we are horrified horrified hold
on I thought I put so much [__] on and
it all disappeared she told me that the
trick is for every single step that you
do whether it's a liquid blush and then
you have to do powder blush she goes you
have to do layers tons of layers of
every step in small amounts but it's
constant reapply reapply not all night
just in the beginning um so that's one
constant reapply but it's really tricky
to not make it look cakey okay another
one I'm really into the fake freckles
right now even though I'm not good at
them and they do look very fake in
person it does make your makeup look
more natural a third one
I would
[Music]
say my favorite skin tint right now the
YSL barely their skin tint is incredible
every single Foundation breaks me out
and it looks cakey and it starts to
crack this looks like skin I'm obsessed
it comes in like a paint tube packaging
Is Not Great not great but I'm obsessed
with it let's see what's another Beauty
tip I have that's good don't touch your
eyebrows I touch that's not true I touch
don't touch them you said that I don't
like I don't like them '90s don't do it
do it also favorite tip ever if you just
want to elevate your makeup just a
little bit and you're like oh I wish
like my eyes like popped a little more I
wish my wing was a little bit farther
out I want to look more snatched and
lifted take a false eyelash cut it in
half put them just on the ends of your
eyes and I'm telling you it just ties
everything together we gave a we gave a
whole well here we are the natur was
girly and like let me show you how to
put on a strip lash I love it all right
so how to feel less awkward initiating
small relationship moves so she also
gave an example which I loved this
example she said taking pictures
together I have a very specific
experience that I can share I love that
she included taking pics together
because I'm one of those girls even if
I'm just sort of in the talking phases
with a guy I just want documentation
evidence of everything like I want to be
able to have these photos I can be like
oh my God like look at the two of us
we're so cute together but I get it it's
weird cuz you're not just going to pull
out your phone and say let's take a
photo together and he's like why I know
exactly how to do it I
recently got a really shitty digital
camera from Etsy and there's something
about using a film camera or a digital
camera that everyone wants to be in the
photo like it doesn't even matter if
this is your first date like and not
only that it just gets pass through
around the room so then you get a 100
photos so I say use a fil or digital cuz
everyone wants that photo later mhm so
this is if you're bringing it to a
party yeah right like if you're bringing
because you wouldn't bring your digital
camera to a first date or like a third
date or whatever I mean I would God but
this is I have a tip for if you don't
have a digital camera because I actually
do agree with that um it's so much more
fun to take it when you know someone has
one camera and you can just be like
smile let's do it so there was a very I
will never forget this experience so
this is my last boyfriend I was visiting
him in New York and I will never forget
the first photo we took because I was so
nervous I will never forget it we're
walking around West Village at the time
I didn't know that and it was February
it's pretty cool but everything looked
really pretty and we were all bundled up
and I just remember thinking it would be
really fun to take a photo in this area
so I saw up ahead a couple like a girl
and a guy and I thought to myself all I
need to do is just say a comment about
the surrounding I was like it's so
pretty here we walk past the people I'm
like hey do you mind taking a photo of
us gave her my phone and we took a photo
if you just not make it a big deal
that's what it is for me in my head I
was freaking out my heart I wanted it so
bad so of course my head and my heart we
work together here and we discovered
that just you know doing it in public
having someone else take the photo of
you just kind of making it a casual pass
by thing you know what I've done one
time I'm so crazy I'm so crazy but I
feel like we all secretly want these
little you know little tokens after a
date or something I one time purposely
researched the nearest photo booth right
and I was like let's go get a drink
after and go to this bar knowing that
there's a photo booth in the basement
right so I was like oh my God a photo
booth here let's get in it and then you
have a roll of four really cute photos
together you never called them back but
like a great memory see that is a cute
one that's cute that's cute that's cute
well that would be way easier if there
was photo booths everywhere I would love
that I would start with just one of
those grocery store film cameras easy
easy easy okay next question how to stay
disciplined on a fitness
journey I am currently on a fitness
journey I'd say are you disciplined mhm
okay I'd say so I mean we got to work on
snacking a little bit I said I was going
to stop mindless snacking I haven't
stopped mindless snacking but but I
think that it's so important to have a
goal in mind to stay disciplined and you
need to also feel like there's an area
where you don't feel so restricted
because like the 8020 rule because I
feel like when you're telling yourself
you can't do something and you have to
do something it's reverse psychology you
end up wanting it more and then you get
a taste and then you lean into it for me
personally right now I'm not saying I'm
doing it but in my head a dream of mine
would be to run the New York City
marathon I know that sounds crazy but
think it would be really cool to
complete that and so right now in my
head I'm saying I'm training for that
I'm not I'm running like two miles a day
but I'm I'm getting really consistent
with it and it's been way more fun to be
involved in my fitness journey knowing
that there's like an end goal to work
towards if that makes sense so I feel
like that's how I was going to say the
same thing I think just mindlessly
working out kind of just feels mundane
and you're not that motivated to do it I
would say Okay Sumer is coming up I want
to be in a crop top and I want to feel
good when I put a crop top on so I'm
like okay I have three months to be
consistent and it really just depends on
what you're looking for yeah I used to
have a very toxic view of like how to
work out and like what I should look
like to the point where like Alexis Ren
in like 2016 was my screen saver as a
reminder of what I should look like now
looking back I'm like that is incredibly
unreal
and just torture yeah I mean I that's
the thing is I used to think like that
too where I was like I know I have to go
on a trip and I need to look good but
I've realized for myself one I really
don't do well with that stuff like I
can't have that as my goal like feeling
good in my clothing to be honest for me
personally it has to be almost a fitness
goal to hit a fitness ending like it has
to be something involving Fitness like
oh I really want to maybe you have a
park near your neighborhood that's like
10 miles away like I really want to be
able to run from like my house to my
park or something that involves your
body physically being active like maybe
not like if you cuz if you say a bikini
you get self-conscious thinking about
yourself in the bikini and you start to
look at your body more as how it'll look
in a bikini rather than like strength
and fitness and healthy mind you know
it's the mindset you go into and the
goal you make has to be as healthy as
that decision I agree and I also think
ways just to keep working out
interesting and fun is constantly change
up the routine do something different
even if it's going for a walk that's
working out but listen to a podcast
watch a YouTube video like so it's
always fresh and new and it doesn't feel
like a chore yeah exactly oh oh oh this
next question is loaded I wrote a really
good one all right okay best piece of
advice in your 20s okay I'm G to write I
wrote this down because that was a
pretty hard one to kind of gather I feel
like it's such a loaded question but
this is just coming from someone that's
currently in her 20s and like hitting
the end of L late 20 mid 20s late 20s
okay don't try to pretend you know
everything allow yourself to learn from
others listen to your guts rather than
the group I always used to think that I
had to listen to everybody else and also
watch everybody else seeing how great
they were doing and that made me feel so
discouraged that I thought I was not
doing well and it made my 20s even more
tough to go through because you're
comparing yourself to everybody I was so
s thinking that I knew exactly who I was
and I knew exactly where I was going
that my that wore me out because when
things didn't go according to plan um
defeat and heartbreak and low
self-esteem settled and we are supposed
to we physically grow in life therefore
our minds du to it changes adapt and
learn to figure out what's needed for
true
happiness thank you and that is a that
is a that was very well said thanks um
my ad my advice for your
20s
um it's okay to not have it all figured
out yeah exactly because if you want
something enough it'll always work its
way out exactly honestly we're saying
the same thing just different ways it's
just you know I think I there were so
many things I wish I did in my 20s
earlier on in terms of I can even get
vulnerable about like relationships
there were I was so set and thinking
like I know how this is going to turn
out I know where I'm going to be I know
what I need to do I know and honestly I
know nothing you know nothing Sophia
Stallone and I feel like every single
year I'm a completely different version
of myself from last year and it's
getting better because I'm understanding
who I am as I go and I think that that's
what you need to kind of give yourself a
break and try to listen and learn from
people yourself and you know healthy
people also don't compare stop comparing
I feel like it's so easy to look at
someone else's life and think oh my god
look how perfect it is it's all fake can
we also be real 20
suck I'm starting to change my mindset
about that because I will be so upset if
I'm 45 with two screaming babies and a
husband that won't talk to me and I'm
looking back I'm like why didn't I enjoy
my 20s more yeah look at my life now
that life sounds really miserable I just
gave myself you said you were 40 I'm
already on divorce number two it's a
mess so yeah she's a chain smoker chain
smoker in private I have so just enjoy
and it's okay to not yeah have it all
figured out and make mistakes and and
and mess up and get messy don't get
messy all right um developing and
maintaining
self-confidence oh God does anyone
really have 100% self-confidence no but
there are ways to kind of trick yourself
I've been working on this in therapy
it's my personality now um and one trick
that my therapist gave me was she wanted
me to write on Post-its like just things
that normally when I would look in the
mirror I would say negatively about
myself and just put them on the mirror
so that first thing in the morning it
could even be like you're so smart
you're a good friend like I love that
you don't have a big forehead like it
could be it could be anything and so
when every time you look in the mirror
every time you walk into the bathroom
it's just a really positive affirmation
I think always having little reminders
that um you know life is too short to
feel like very discouraged angry about
low self-esteem 100% fake it till you
make it and then eventually you're going
to believe it guys walk into the room
with your shoulders back surround
yourself with people that only tell you
good things about yourself that only
want to encourage you
also this is the best piece of advice
this you and I can both unanimously
agree on what is
it nothing makes you feel more hot then
than self-tanning actually was really
funny this girl s the video If I Was A
therapist and my client said she was
really sad I would say to her have you
ever considered self tanning fake
tanning I'm telling you right now that
[__] makes me go from Zero to Hero I
look hot I put on my face before I got
here yeah see there's a reason why I
look like Casper and she's looking like
but don't look at my hands agre God
don't look at my hands don't look at her
hands okay I like that um things to talk
about on dates so the conversation
doesn't end oh man I really got to go
into my Satchel of Rogue date questions
let's see this one men seem to like I've
used this one a couple times always seem
to like it I think do you have like
specific a specific question okay I
don't have specific but I kind of have
an a thing I do okay I'd like to hear
that after okay it sounds kind of corny
saying it out loud but I always ask and
this is when you really are struggling
to find conversation if you could have
any career any job in the world you know
pay doesn't matter and you'd be really
good at it what would you do because
then that way it kind of Sparks more of
like a creativity side of them or
something that's really that they're
interested in besides working at like a
finance firm and then you can kind of
just ask a billion questions about that
and there's always a tie there's always
a story there's always a reason for why
they want to pursue that career like for
example I always say my dream career
would be to do horror movie Prosthetics
and do like really gory gross makeup and
then they're going to say why and then
we'll get into a whole conversation
about why I like scary movies perfect
okay so the best way I think to continue
and keep a good conversation going is to
follow R LR and I always do this read
listen
respond so basically what I'm saying is
when you're sitting on a date focus on
the girl in front of you or the guy read
their body language are they someone
that's a instant talker are they someone
that's more quiet are they someone that
you know do they perk up a certain topic
do they you know when you read their
profile when you looked at their
Instagram like you saw some things that
you you know probably have a common
interest in or things you can bring up
so read them listen listen to the way
they kind of go back and forth if you're
kind of going crazy and they're not
really going crazy it kind of you know
causes a little bit of a imbalance you
have to kind of listen to the way they
respond cuz I sometimes I'll like study
someone and I'll see and you do this too
we kind of adapt I'm not saying you
should adapt this person but I think a
really good way when you're on a date is
to just kind of match each other's
energy levels like you know you don't no
one needs to push too hard or like try
too hard or be too cool then be chill
chill like just you know kind of go off
and you know then respond then you ask
the right questions see what things that
they're interested in and I I have been
trying to do this now whenever the
conversation would Lull in the past I
would try to overcompensate by doing all
the talking and then by the time
dinner's over you're exhausted and you
feel drained and you're like oh my God
that was just not enjoyable for me at
all right so going off of what you were
saying if he's really not putting in
that much effort match that and maybe
take a step back and say if we're not
able to have this natural banter then
maybe we just don't click R LR read
listen respond that was like very formal
I didn't even write that down that I
actually forgot to add that in my notes
so amazing okay
how this question I love that was a
great question this question how to tap
into your divine feminine energy and
attract more
men okay I would say I have this problem
and so does cine cine was saying it
we're my mom just roasted me about this
yesterday on the phone we're not like
girl we're girly but we're not as you
can tell we're a little bit dominating
listen I was in a bit of a pickle we'll
say with Mr Pickle's an understatement
with Mr you guys know the
story what do you want from me nothing
that guy he's back no yes
no
but I have always had this hard exterior
and if someone pisses me off I'll write
them off really quick I'll say screw you
I'm out but inside a mush and it kills
me and it makes me really really sad and
I was talking about it with my mom
because an instance just happened with
Mr Pickle I love this name for him Mr
Pickle and she was pretty much schooling
me saying that I try so hard to be the
dominant one in every relationship and I
try so hard to be the man and I initiate
every hard conversation and I say my
feelings first and I don't ever show a
vulnerable sensitive side because in my
brain I think that means weakness and
she was saying that I need to start
acting more as the woman in the
relationship and I know that's like
we're not saying women are weak or or
Meek or quiet or shy or softspoken but
more just don't take all of the
responsibilities from both sides and on
yourself she goes take a step back take
a let him kind of shower you with with
these conversations let him initiate and
not feel so you know stressed out byly
trying to play every role there's a
couple ways you can kind of go about it
because I've been learning and actually
researching a little bit on how to tap
in because I'm the same way I'm someone
that I'm very honest and I'm very
vulnerable but not vulnerable with guys
that I'm with I'm almost I I'm
vulnerable to like the the Buzzard the
Buzzard hits and I'm like this is how
I'm feeling um but ways I think that you
know these are like small things that
I've read about that really probably
help you tap into this like a little bit
more plateful energy is a good way is
complimenting others and also taking on
compliments instead of you know when you
go out you giving energy to someone that
is a positive affirmation or something
that's just going to make their day that
energy is going to come back to you and
then two when someone compliments you
take it say thank you and believe it
because that person isn't just throwing
out compliments people don't need to
compliment a compliment it's not
people's nature to always be nice and if
someone's saying you look beautiful be
like thank you like I do look beautiful
that's great I think another way is to
you know not be so serious and lean into
that playful side I think everyone has a
silly playful light side and you know
when it comes to dating and it comes to
men I think that we you know tend to be
very headyy about it and that is what
causes us to be a little bit more Stern
about things we try to read it we try to
indulge in it we try to you know kind of
control it and I think that when it
comes to that tap into the you know
Carefree if it works it works it doesn't
it doesn't and that gives you a little
bit of mystery and it gives you a bit of
you know confidence that you know you're
not depending on this person to be your
end all be all but you're enjoying the
company that you're having but I do
understand why women and men too but
we're women so we're going to speak as
women why they would feel the need to
kind of put up a little bit of a guard
and you know keep a three-foot distance
and never let anyone too close because
everyone every single person has dealt
with some sort of heartbreak hardship
just you know sadness vulnerability and
it gets thrown back in your face in a
relationship before so a big issue that
I've been trying to work through is just
because someone made a mistake in a
prior relationship of mine I don't want
to carry that onto every single future
person I go out with because one that's
not fair to them but that's also not
fair to myself so still me having this
wall up and not letting anyone in too
close and then the second they get too
close I sort of push them away I don't
know it it's very tough but it's
something you have to constantly remind
yourself that not everyone is bad and
and feeling loved and showered isn't
also weak no it's it's accepting it like
accepting the compliments that's a part
of love it's accepting you know the
attention that's part of love but also
in your own way be confident in your
beliefs be confident in your love and
enjoy the love in life God I don't know
if this episode just gave me more
anxiety and really made me look inward
you're about to have she's going on a
really really really really really
really fun date tonight she's going to a
basketball game yeah it is with Mr
Pickle
so because Mr Pickle listens to this he
might he doesn't I can guarantee it okay
so that is pretty much all the questions
we have um I will bring in the journal
next week I'm so sorry I didn't do it
this time that was probably
subconsciously my body is forcing Sophia
have a great time on your bachelorette
trip thank you I'll miss you have a
great time on your date tonight shut up
it'll be fun I can't wait to hear about
it all right we love you guys we'll see
you next Tuesday bye